okay hello everybody
we are playing resident evil 4 in oculus
right now this is my first time
recording an oculus gameplay um i tried
a little bit of it first to like
play with the settings and the setup
that i have here seems to be the best
option the game is about half the screen
and then i am the other half but i'm so
stoked about this so we're going to try
as long as i can make the tech work it's
really hard to record vr with no help
it's just me like kind of having to
monitor my recordings while playing in
oculus it's very difficult but if it
works and it doesn't make you guys sick
to look at or is it annoying to watch
we're going to try and play through the
entirety of resident evil 4
in
oculus quest 2 which is awesome
so let's let's do this i'm
i've been so excited about this and when
i jumped into like i said like record a
little bit of it i'm just like
blown away by how cool it is um
so let's just press any button you even
have his hands and watch so cool press
any button you have to press a
four
all right and then we're gonna go um
i want a new game
we'll go normal
next
i can jump through all of this pretty
well because i already did it i wouldn't
be surprised sorry to my settings but
yeah basically has a full settings menu
we're gonna go full motion i am worried
that that will be a little bit
uncomfortable for people on the internet
to watch because that's the way you have
to turn you see it's like
um
but i don't know i i'm cool with it
we'll see how people feel about it after
i upload this one
finish oh let's go
stopped
let's do it i'm so stoked
1998
i'll never forget it
i never would have thought the first
time that i played this game which i've
actually never finished by the way there
are parts of resident evil 4 that like
i'm not going to know about the whole
world i played it as a kid the fault of
a secret viral experiment conducted by
the international pharmaceutical
enterprise
um at somebody else's house
and then again
in a nearby mountain community raccoon
city well i love this game it hit the
peaceful little town this is this is so
devastating
going to be my first time actually
finishing it which is super exciting
not taking any chances the president of
the united states ordered a contingency
plan
to sterilize fracking city
with a whole affair gone public
the united states government issued an
indefinite suspension of business decree
to umbrella
soon its stock prices crashed and for
all intents and purposes all right
mystery solved umbrella dead
everything's fine raccoon city saved
all good
what else could that be for leon to do
our hero is jobless
six years have passed since that
horrendous incident
[Music]
i received special training a secret
organization yeah this is how it gives
you
cutscenes it's like we're all in this
like theater
responsibility of protecting the new
president's family
why am i the one who always gets the
shorting of this cake you
who are really
come on
just some hunk from america from home
cowboy
you have my sympathies guess that's a
local's way of breaking the ice
anyway you know what this is all about
my assignment is to search for the
president's missing daughter right
all by yourself
i'm very capable just
then again maybe you did
oh you're crazy american it's a direct
order from the chief himself
i tell you it's no picnic
i'm counting on you guys
man they ain't gonna do [ __ ] sorry dude
you why would you count on these dudes
specifically
do they know about umbrella
no i guess it contacts at this point in
the game
umbrella isn't an issue
it was right before i was to take on my
duties of protecting the president's
daughter when she was abducted
that's the ultimate reason i'm in this
lonely and rural part of europe doesn't
sound so bad dude i'd take that
intelligence there's reliable
information about a sighting of a girl
that looks very similar to the
president's daughter
apparently she's being withheld by some
unidentified group of people
who would have thought that my first job
would have been a rescue mission
yeah you can see my calories up there by
the
way
you can say most things
quest two for fitness you'll only tell
me i look up
here turn it off
it's probably nothing it's probably not
there must be my imagination sometimes
you just get a bit of cold deck and and
you know
you just gotta put your pants back on
and enjoy the ride that is life
what happens to the best of us dude you
know
no stress no sweat
i'll go and have a look around
i will stay and watch that car great i
was worried about the car i don't want
to get any parking tickets thank you
that's super helpful right parking
tickets good luck
geez who are these guys
very cool
no no no just talk about how cool
okay
this is like a pokedex it's so for me
i'm ingrid hunnigan i'll be your support
on this mission right
loud and clear
so the subject's name's ashley graham
right that's right she's the daughter of
the president so try to behave yourself
okay
is she hot whoever this group is they
sure picked the wrong girl to kidnap
well it seems like it might have been
some more information on mine
smartest deduction there good talk to
you later leon
out okay
uh i'm actually gonna skip it because
i've done it before
when i was setting up um but check this
out hitting that
[Laughter]
i love it so much you have to i have to
grab the knife from my titty
titty knife
oh it's my favorite okay
so yeah this is how it looks it'll
probably take me a couple of days to get
the next episode of this up
that was stupid it's resident evil why
wait on that um because i do want to use
your feedback for like how how turning
works and everything um to see what you
guys think
of how i have this set up right now
but it works for me
i um don't have the ability to get it to
go 360 from what i can tell
okay
[Music]
try me
punk
uh excuse me just sir
he's dirty it means he's evil you should
know that
and his eyes were expressed i might
recognize the girl in this photograph
okay
sorry to have bothered you
dos
this is a different guy leon this isn't
dick cold guy okay grab grandma put it
in the gun the coolest thing in the
world and then shoot the man
correct
[Music]
i wonder if i can jewel it i'm gonna
drop titty knife also i can
oh i never felt so powerful
oh some friends do you think they have
any mozzarellas
is everything okay there was a hostel
local i had no choice but to neutralize
it there are still others you did try to
kill me with an axe for some reason get
out of there and head toward the village
take whatever measures necessary to save
the subject understood
all right
everybody calm down i'll be there in a
minute in just a second
okay
money
it's not a zombie i love that leon has
this like
kind of zombie ptsd he's just super
worried
yeah
yeah that's not
my favorite none of this is interact
with the ball
that's pretty rank actually
okay
i see you
what do you got that guy has a gun
no that's not a gun that's a hatchet
a lot of melee weapons out here that's
that's okay it's fine
love some handgun emma
all right boys let me grab
crap
gun
and then
jump out this window really get the jump
on him
teddy knife
what are you gonna do
oh oh he ran in
is that everybody music changed i think
we're all right
okay
oh [ __ ]
my microphone
it'll happen
um we have to be real slashy with it
okay
what do you got for me boss man what's
this
am i
i don't mind if i do how about you
it will be you
more money type
all right so they drove away right they
really just left me here
yep
oh
oh they go they
they got pushed off
oh no
well
that's a shame
um who else am i gonna ask for my zannas
now for the record everybody i spent uh
like a month in nicaragua this year
and duolingo
something was interactive all here
signpost reads pueblo
um joey lingard really teaches you how
to ask for apples
i didn't expect to end up in a
spanish-speaking country and i did
anybody
um oh i hear a dog
and so you know when you try to learn
teddy knife
thank you
um you just you just really get the
basics and um
i know how to ask to coffee beer and
apples oh we lost recording give me a
second
okay i see shiny item i get shiny item i
don't make the rules i just play them
that's how that saying goes right
oh
oh signpost what does it say
guy post reads pueblo oh that's it i'm
still just going to the same place
all right
those are mines
traps
can't walk through there let's just
push
what an aggressive explosion
are you still alive wow the gray head
ones are stuck
you have anything on me dude okay
you got any [ __ ] for me to steal
nope all right
keep rolling
i wonder if he had any manzanas
okay
i don't oh
oh my oh my
she
is
well
the blood dripping makes it seem fresh
but then she's like turned to stone so
teddy knife
i don't want to hit my desk again okay
great
love all of that for me go
all right let's roll
everything is so much scarier in vr like
a person approaching you
it's just the most terrifying thing
that's ever happened to you even though
it's not no you don't
stay
[ __ ] stay down
give me what is it
everybody's got treasure on them this is
this place is great
what is uh daenerys
it's money
i can make this shot let's see how that
you even know the sights goes
great
[ __ ]
in your face
he was actually kind of handsome
same as the guy in the house
but still handsome
okay
yes please
teddy knife
i really do just hit myself in the boob
every time
you too
[Music]
great
good
okay let's roll is this locked this
looks locked
hello okay i'm good
let's roll
yes
leon how you holding up it's pretty
messed up out here sorry to hear that
i'm sending you a playing manual hope
you find it useful thank you i'll take a
look at it thanks why'd you say it that
way
uh pause menu oh good to know
ah
the play manager provides useful
information on controls game settings
and options
wait did you tell me to do something
i don't feel like i need any of this
right now key items come in various
shapes and sizes
this is very resident evil first
interact with the block by using the a
button then grab the appropriate item
from the ui is it going to show up is
what i'm guessing
yeah that's interesting oh that's cool
okay
that's fine i don't feel like i need any
of this right now
do you want me to
i missed whatever it told me to do
pan the map by pressing and holding the
trigger on either controller by pointing
in the center panel whoa
zoom map in and out filters
okay
cool
weapons and recovery
hey inventory yeah
oh i love it
i mean how do i organize the same way
that i normally would organize though
like can i just grab this and then oh my
god yes
inventory management i'm gonna i want to
place it there
and then we'll just stack you
oh
oh
this is good content this is this is
what we're here for
inventory stacking i could combine you
oh that's really easy to do
that's cool
i would love a two-handed weapon or a
grenade but i don't have one
the map shows the current position
points of interest and areas within a
story chapter
eat
oh my god look at all those lock doors
why am i my
hell yeah
okay cool
files
the files area is collected of all the
notes
info on ashley
she's 20. that is not a 20 year old
why would you lie to my face like that
she is clearly not 20.
cannot buy an unidentified group while
on our way home from university the
kidnapper's motives are still unknown
although there's reliable information
the puppetry is an insider that girl is
about 10.
only a handful of people know this about
this kidnapping it's been kept under
wraps mostly due to the fact we can't
determine who the trader is
the guys in intelligence say they have a
reliable information that ashley's being
been cited somewhere in europe until we
find out who the insider is i don't know
what to believe i could be a floyd it
could be a boy very few leads as to the
whereabouts of ashley but members of the
secret service and anyone else related
to ashley being questioned
even active agents are being
investigated for any information all
right neat
um exit
okay
oh no
that's a lot of them are they all mean
are all of you mean is what i would like
to know
i'm gonna guess you're all mean
that's a man being burned at the stake
probably not
super positive people to be around
take that give it give
[Music]
can i kill this [ __ ] with a knife maybe
what if they're friendly
again
i doubt it
hello
not friends
i gave you a chance
oh
what the [ __ ]
get off there
oh my god
i'm sorry
maybe i just killed his wife you know
that doesn't even seem
like it was
like
i've just really hurt that
how are you still alive
oh yeah stop with the throwing hatchets
at me nope get away from me
oh my god
all right
you guys okay in there
don't you dare throw that at me
stay down okay
i just let them out didn't i
[Applause]
i just i want to pop everybody's heads
up oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you're very close
you're very close
uh medical screen is on my shoulder
isn't it
get down woman
it's like oh it's here nice
that rules oh my god
no no no no no
emma hammer ammo
get away from me
personal space
all right get
out of it
[Applause]
um some wasted shots here with my stress
[ __ ] off dude [ __ ] off dude i don't like
that face i don't like her face at all
oh my god oh my god
no
jesus christ
oh
oh god no you don't like it when they
run
and they keep coming
how many of you are there
oh oh oh oh this is scripted isn't it
i remember this
isn't it a thing where they literally do
just keep [ __ ] coming hang on i don't
know that i have any more [ __ ] health
out here lads
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] your knife
that was very stressful i wow
i am i am dead
i should
be doing a better job of everything but
it's a lot to manage especially when you
keep punching your own microphone
you know what i'm saying
there's a lot going on here okay
we have a fair amount of ammo
um i don't remember i feel like like
this is like a scripted segment but i
don't remember what i'm supposed to do
is it lost a certain amount of time or
get to a certain location i remember
this one last time i played this game
but
um
i don't remember what what the actual
outcome is supposed to be
all right everybody try me try me try me
try
okay i'm just gonna back it [ __ ] up
so that at least i can see y'all coming
ain't nobody gonna get to jump on me
back here
you know what i mean
[Applause]
and i can kind of straight from here too
which is nice
[Applause]
[ __ ] they are behind me [ __ ]
oh no
leon can we move it like a little bit
faster just like a tiny bit faster spray
ammo ammo [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god
oh my god oh my god i'm so [ __ ]
stressed
that sounds like somebody behind me
again can you die could you all just die
ammo okay we'll take this we'll take
this could i have it thank you
[Music]
they run really fast too
[Applause]
i youtube really i just need you to die
[Applause]
oh my god
town's so big and so angry
that was gonna happen [ __ ] no oh god
this oh god
they're so close oh [ __ ] i'm out all
right next time
uh inventory
nope just pause the game this is so hard
in vr
oh god okay
that's all right it's all right i'll
make it happen
maybe we need to push through it
like go further
and i also really
just waste that i don't know
okay
i know i know this is supposed to be
this way i just don't remember why
oh hang on let me take that and then
inventory
and do some combining bites
i'll take you i would take a u and i put
you with you thank you very much
very very much okay back to the video
game
i just really like shooting this lady in
the head huh and it's really
my ammo
excuse me love
you know that at some point somebody
comes from behind oh it's e3
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that's good that's good
give me give me
give give
give i take i take this
yes
camera
[Applause]
we're doing all right we're doing all
right
[Music]
[ __ ] out of here
i don't buy that i just did that maybe
yeah there's still tons of them there
but maybe now i can grab some [ __ ] you
know
that's super helpful
oh grenade
okay cool
grenades oh is grenade on on other titty
uh echo shut up
show your mouth
all right lads i'm not sure where
grenade is located
you should be dead woman
gosh
oh my god okay i would love to use this
hold everybody just give me a second so
i can figure out how to use it
um
why
how
i want to use it
maybe it's in options
uh
no
weapons and recovery no that's that's
just the inventory files
what is this one um
[Music]
general
selection stick
um
i don't remember where
the
grenade lives and that is gonna cause me
some changes some problems right now
so i could really [ __ ] use it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
these [ __ ] i swear to god
okay
grenade
tip maybe
uh i don't know where it is
hey
who is that harming on it
oh my god
okay it's down here some it's it is on
this titty i knew it
[Music]
i think it's like a time limit i really
don't remember i know that this is a
thing in this game though
okay it is cool that this is like
everyone going the way that i'm getting
experienced resident evil 4 i thought
about replaying it a million times but
doing it like this
is awesome
hello
yes you called hunnicutt i have some bad
news i've confirmed the body of an
officer
something's happened to the people here
leon you need to get out of there look
for a tower and follow the trail near it
got it
which button x
okay
s is typewriter that's locked though i'd
love to be able to save
but i can't save a locked door
damn that's harsh
okay let me pull that up again
where am i facing right now i need to go
around this way i wish i could save dude
can i maybe break through it
it's this building right here
is that luton to be done
anybody anybody in here anybody
all right okay what do you got for me
what do you got what do you got what you
got
push
huh
did you barricade the door
nope nope nope um i'm trying to see if
there's anything in there but i guess
no
that's obviously very padlocked
that's the room where they all went i
think
i need that key
but isn't that where my typewriter is
though
oh don't mind if i do
surely i can grab that from
thank you very much
[ __ ]
a lot of you you're all sons of [ __ ]
i said what i said
okay
i'm very surprised oh hello
titty knife i'm just gonna
[Music]
are you okay bud oh you placid
[Music]
oh that was an accident i'm just trying
to pat him okay i didn't mean
i didn't mean to do that
it was an accident
i hope he's okay oh that's the opposite
[Applause]
yeah that's a shame
by the way if you ever see me do that
when i'm looking up it's me trying to
check that the screen's still recording
okay so
um all right
[Applause]
well that's [ __ ] terrifying
[Music]
jesus you just have this in your house
also where do people sleep
[Music]
i like that i summon it like a pokemon
personally just open
i don't want to hit my desk
yes
give me get all right
let me
move back a little bit further even okay
that's as far back as i can get with my
green screen set up currently
it should be all right
hey just some added difficulty never
hurt anybody
nicely on that was cool as [ __ ]
i will take that thank you
am i supposed to kill these chickens
like in
in eight
[Music]
so i
don't really want to let's try
i don't know why i thought i would be
able to do this i can't even open a box
i'm gonna kill this chicken with a knife
come on now
no
if i do i'll come back you know that's
how the game is played
um okay
oh
oh
a shiny thing
egg
yes i take egg yes you give me egg thank
you
[Applause]
and i think that i just have to like
check stuff right nothing useful
like this
no that's pushing
i don't need to i survived wifi
don't mind if i do
oh thank you
grab a shoulder
sweet
oh cool
oh my god that's so cool what the hell
so it's over shoulder
grab
oh my god that rules
all right i think that's everything
um
we gotta go up this way then
is the map gonna show me if i've missed
anything in an open area nah but i feel
like i explored pretty much everything
here
except for this maybe
oh i did all right we're good we're good
we're good
what else you got for me i don't this
this is suspicious like i don't trust
that nobody's coming right now oh what
are you
read
[Music]
recently there has been information that
the united states government agent is
here investigating the village not let
this american agent get in contact with
the prisoner
for those of you not yet informed the
prisoner is being held at an old house
beyond the farm great
we will transfer the prisoner to a
muscular location in the valley when we
are ready the prisoner is to stay there
until further notice meanwhile do not
let the american agent need the prisoner
we do not know how the american
government found out about our village
but we are investigating however i feel
this
intrusion at this particular time is not
just a coincidence i sense a third party
other than the united states government
involved here my fellow men stay alert
chief victoris mendes
okay
that's me i'm famous the people here
love me
that's okay well i don't love that room
creepy as [ __ ]
um i'd love to type right up but i
understand it's in a locked building
it is what it is it is what it is
okay
inventory
or just non-descriptive non-descript box
you seem like you need to be shot
[Music]
so i'm a shooter
but they're not going to come infinitely
this time right
they're good sir
he's just still over there doing his
yard work
[Music]
god yes you take a lot of hits to the
face lads
just a whole lot
all right there we go everybody's down
also mike
okay
oh my god thank you
all right i think this is actually the
part where i'm gonna stop because i can
also only really play this for this long
um i'm just starting to get motion sick
so we will stop here i think this is
super cool
and um we will save
and we because we can call it things
no music can i go down
you need me to overwrite that's fine
[Music]
yes
yes
unless i can go down and i just haven't
figured out how to do that yet but you
know what we'll get there
beautiful
um
yeah this is super cool it's definitely
a little bit janky obviously i keep
punching things i need to set myself up
a little bit further back which i've
learned from playing for a little bit
longer now
um but it is super cool so yeah let me
know if everything looks okay on your
end the quality isn't gonna be great
because the way that i'm casting i can't
get it to be 360. um but i love this so
far i think it's freaking awesome so
thank you all for watching it feels
weird to do this for that
i'm taking a headset up good tan line
look at it oh beautiful
see you guys next time